la
syrie la mémoire geomod tremblay
fille et la terreur et léo c'est quoi
qu'est ce qui à valérie cce tout va bien
j'ai pas la fin tout c'est sûr qu'on va
pas se faire engueuler donne
d'être un citoyen d'elano alors pas la
photo qui joue à l'amour non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ils pas tous mes pattes au calme aux
toiles j'ai pas sale
oui c'est moi mais je ne suis pas
salvadou
fatou photo cyril hanouna
wii fit mine comment vas-tu
sava fatou de c'est
pas tout ça va métier c'est le coeur
lourd que je t'appelle ma chérie
je t'aime beaucoup à tous bah oui ou et
usant pour la tête tu nous réclament ta
bague non tu peux la bague tu peux la
garder ma chienne même tellement que tu
me réclament cas vague la bac tu peux la
garder la seule chose que je te demande
c'est la vérité alors avec un grand v
qui par rapport à quoi où es-tu fatou
je suis à dakar je suis en famille je
suis au sénégal
d'accord il fatto j'ai trop posé la même
question la vérité
pour et de ma famille à tous
va-t-on comment se fait-il que tu sois
parti pour la saint-valentin fatto
je sois là
si
longtemps c'est tous les jours
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît ne se plait je n'aurai
qu'une chose à te dire arrête tu es
salaam allègre à tout
va tout lâcher hanouna la 1e
on a tout eu
comment se fait-il que tu sois parti
maintenant
[Musique]
j'espère la saint-valentin
d'accord donc tu es ce que
fatou qu tu veux m'assurer qu'à dakar
tu es seul avec ta famille
à tous est ce qu'il t'avait d'être main
dans la main avec ton cousin
[Rires]
[Musique]
pour la paix du ménage
est parfaitement je suis d'accord mais
dis donc pas tout on peut avoir
confiance on peut faire l'émission
tranquille
et ben non
[Rires]
faton est de retour tu as à béton
oui
d'accord gilles a quelque chose à dire
pour la saint-valentin parce que fatou
tu m'as convaincu
tu m'as convaincu fatou
je tatoue en tout cas je ne sais pas su
lier la vérité mais tu très persuasive
bravo faction sa touche pas que gilles
et fatou on t'aime tu sais
on t'aime fatou
le bateau je suis avec gilles
tu as quelques mètres de moi
il est à quelques encablures l'a donc si
tu pouvais un lever le pied sur nos
débats merci
à tous
photo je serai je serai dakar
certainement vendredi
photo cette page il
fatto je te passe gilles et pato je vais
te laisser une minute pour lui dire
toute la vérité
gilles c'est pour toi c'est pas tout
ça va série excusez moi mais par contre
ton mal déjà voulait mettre la musique
on peut noter coeur ça va alors voila tu
sais ce qu'on va faire et c'est ce qu'on
va faire parce qu'on a en direct là
alors on va faire une révélation à cyril
on va lui dire ce que tu m'as dit hier
voilà tu vas lui dira cyril il vat
entendre qu est ce que tu es parti faire
préparer le mariage
c'est bon de crier victoire c'est bien
avec gilles
tous ne l'a jamais fatwa sur tennessee
par les familles j'aimerais qu'elle dise
oui
mais il vient de lui quand même
il va passer quand même une n'est pas
invité d'accord et le mariage sert au
sénégal
alors à tous photo
fa tous et moi c'est cyrille
patoux à toi tu regardes de dire nous
dira pas tout que ça y est vous allez
vous marier avec gilles
fatou
au sénégal
n'étant pas d'accord wade au sénégal
avec si génial qu'on sera invité
tous invités alors y en a que pour des
raisons bien sûr pécuniaire
je serai là alors pas tout je viendrai h
le et là je viens vers vous et bien dans
les hôtels n'est pas comme une fois
que je serai là ma chérie je serai là
est flou fatou je voulais dire que c'est
un très grand jour pour nous parce que
pour la saint valentin on pouvait pas
rêver
pas tous je suis très heureux pour toi
ma chérie vraiment parce que j'y croyais
plus à ce mariage
non mais c'est vrai il ya eu deux
mariages auxquels je croyais plus et
tais-toi et gilles et raymond domenech
estelle denis il
y en a des mots qui va se faire
non mais c'est vrai c'est fou et je vais
être passé gilles parce que il veut te
dire quelque chose
gilles n'est pas blanc bleu depuis sept
mois
j'ai la flemme vous comptez tout gâcher
je veux la vérité sur daniel moreau
la touchpad gilles tatoué et merci fatou
thiam dit lippi lui ce qui lui était lu
ce que tu veux mais divisés au petit
coeur the theme merci d'avoir
on va tous les invités
[Rires]
magie
à
à l'image il la royale union et georges
il nous a bien venu mais franchement
imany ma fille est ce que sitôt qu'on
veut rien ils m'apprécient j'en ris
savais que j'avais eu grâce et chluda
lalalala savait pas et après pour me
dire bah je l'habille tiendrait pas
c'est fou et gilou z'amours entend
bientôt ses plus beaux jours du très
heureux mais je ne savais pas du tout ce
qu'on sait manier que fatou si sûr abbas
et elle vous l'a dit on dirait on a dit
pas 'je
aller bouffer
[Applaudissements]
dans les mines connu
ça mais c'est vrai à laval on dit donc
gilles meyer elle m'a dit ça mais ciel
qui t'a demandé en fait qui t'a dit
selma 10 s est pas fait comme ça elle
tagne ouvriers passent canada kabaka
parce que je veux tu as des papiers elle
règle les intervenants non mais elle
n'est pas parti pour préparer le mariage
nous expliquait elle est partie pour des
papiers urgent à elle a été invitée à un
mariage dès son arrivée samedi dimanche
deux jours et elle m'a dit franchement
il faut qu'on aille se maria dakar et
moi je vous dit on chez aspar ans 1
victoire
j'ai raison ces paquets un clair mais
sans éclat
j'adore fatou mais les partenaires de la
carte pour partir à damer les mecs mais
plus connu sou pas vu des mecs
connaissez pas les techniques de ces
deux oui mais les délégués de chagas
mais je connais moi là mais dis moi je
suis un renard argenté m'a
promis un bail à dire mais tu crois que
oui
on va se marier après quand tu es ma
mère
jacques raynal
toi jean patrice je me vengerai d'abord
avec moi ce soir
ça déconne et à la calotte à la capitale
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est fou
sans déconner c'est pas poli tous les
moyens sont bons
gilles est ce que c'est alors question
pour la saint valentin est ce que si
fatou n'est pas au courant voilà l
époque ou en personne ne le saura est ce
que tu pourrais passer la nuit avec
dernier le mot mais personne ne le sait
même pas toi personne de cet incident
mais lui le sait
[Rires]
ça
c'est vrai elle c'est very bad trip
non mais sérieux alors mais est ce que
oui ou non non je pensais que vous étiez
mon ami vous de jouer mais personne
d'autre choix l'anti pour daniel allawi
c'est la vérité c'est fait ou non mais
elle est fausse et futurs
[Applaudissements]